one thing that won't be in place much
longer is the replay assistant
potentially the replay assistant could
be morphing into a booth umpire this is
something the ravens are
proposing for the second straight year
and this booth umpire sky judge is also
the term that's used for this is exactly
the thing miles that i have been banging
on the table for
for years and it's very simple and i've
gotten the materials that the ravens
have submitted to the league and i've
read over the proposed rule is very
simple it just expands the the number of
officials to eight and it adds the name
booth umpire to field judge back judge
all the other
folks that they currently have
on the field and i've said for years
that
they need to have someone who is calling
the game
with the benefit of the tv angles that
we see at home to bridge the gap between
viewer
and participant
because you've got middle-aged folks who
have no pads no helmets trying to
survive among the gladiators and also
while trying not to get trampled by the
gladiators who are wearing body armor
and very hard helmets and sharp cleats
they're using their naked eye to see
these things that are just whizzing by
them so you put someone in a booth who
sees what we see at home and
communicates directly to the referee the
referee is still in charge still in
charge of the crew but it's no different
than the caucuses we see all the time
where officials get together and make
sure they're getting the call right and
you've got someone who's got the benefit
of seeing exactly what we see to help
them get the call right it is beautiful
in its simplicity
the nfl doesn't like
like to change things they don't like to
do it unless they have to one of the
arguments the ravens make is is simple
it's going to happen eventually why not
go ahead and do it now
well that i think is just the biggest
thing why why not do something that
certainly seems like it's inevitable but
also i just don't really understand what
the argument is to not do it
because at this point especially when
we're all sitting at home and i mean how
many times do we text back and forth on
sundays mike you know
in our group
how do they miss that and we all see it
we all see the replay instantly and so
why do we have to now
at this point at least takes so much
time to maybe do a replay to say oh my
goodness this is not called on the field
properly but now it's not actually
actually reviewable so they can't do it
if we have this sky judge or the booth
umpire then we don't have to worry about
those kinds of things that get it right
the first time and mike that's why i
just say what is the argument against
doing this i don't really understand
what it would be
and and it's
unintended consequences that that is the
vague we're going to hide under the bed
for fear of unintended consequences the
reality is you should be able with the
application of foresight and creativity
to anticipate all consequences make them
expected not unintended are you talking
about smart people who can get in a room
and brainstorm well what about this what
about this i could see this happen i can
see that the nfl never does that they
just they go forward
and then
they see what happens and and look at
what happened with the past interference
replay review procedures from two years
ago and and the way that that was a
disaster miles i think that will make
them less inclined
to take chances this is one though that
they need and one of the reasons they
need it
as legalized gambling spreads
these calls become more important and
even if the nfl is never going to get
100 of the calls right they need to
create the impression that they're
trying to get 100 of the calls right and
they're doing everything reasonably
within their power to do so the only
argument against it is
dollars and cents we're not gonna get
the bang for the buck whatever it costs
to hire
one extra member of the crew
for every crew that we have and put the
technology in place and have that booth
available and every other expense that
goes along with it what is the
incremental gain well i think there will
be an incremental gain in the accuracy
of calls also you won't be using replay
review as often because the booth umpire
corrects it before replay has to and
also it will boost morale you've got
less controversies and i you know we
shouldn't
we shouldn't scoff at that one at one
point jeff fisher when he was the rams
coach and on the competition committee
he said i think tongue-in-cheek
well you know we we like to give you
guys some things to talk about on monday
no these are not the good things to talk
about on monday officiating
controversies are not ideal and in a
world of legalized gambling miles it is
something the nfl should avoid because
if it gets bad enough
the nfl will find itself subject to
regulation by some sort of governmental
agency you know the sec securities and
exchange commission
did not arrive until 1934 before that
there was no federal regulation of the
stock markets it took the crash of 29
plus five years
to create the sec so at some point
because you're gonna have people
wagering money millions if not billions
of dollars at some point there'll be a
scandal
that sparks congress to create an agency
that'll regulate the nfl and the best
thing that the nfl can do is keep its
backyard clean so congress doesn't come
along at some point and say we're going
to clean it up for you booth umpire sky
judge that's part of the process of
getting them to where they need to be
you could have gone with the consumer
financial protection bureau you know
that would have been a more recent
reference mike than when you were alive
but i wasn't you know all the way back
in the 1930s
well i i thank you very much i i i i've
been using the i actually looked up when
the sec came into existence because i
was concerned you know i really i i
think the nfl needs to be worried about
this and i don't think it's good for
anybody if there is a federal agency
that has regulatory power over the nfl
the nfl doesn't want that the nfl
doesn't want anyone other than the nfl
telling the nfl what to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports